you know they have been under estimating
us all our lives
it was a fairy tale the two of them
against the world she understood him and
knew him and what he needed he was a
very private individual by all reports
very shy so he had a very good manner of
dealing with people but there was always
a space and I think Nancy filled that
space for him when they were with each
other they could be themselves
especially Nancy when she was not being
watched when she was nothing was
expected of her she could just be
herself and that's how that's in the
script in the film I hope that's where
you'll see a kind of intimacy that you
can only imagine Ronald Reagan never
would have overcome his wound inflicted
by John Hinckley if he if Nancy Reagan
had not been there every step of the way
he depended on Nancy Reagan after he was
shot for almost everything
psychologically emotionally even
physically she didn't run the country
she ran him and who needed that there is
a moment in the movie where and this
comes after the assassination attempt
where Nancy goes to her husband and
tries to convince him that
to hire an astrologer to warn them when
they're gonna have bad days ahead
there's been mockery made of her as a
result of that decision and the control
that she sort of seized in the the
abject and determined protection of her
husband which is all understandable I
think what is so affecting in that scene
both in how it's written and performed
is you immediately can feel the
underlying love that is motivating all
of this when she sits on Ronald Reagan's
lap and she looks him deeply in the eye
and begs us of them you can see concern
on the gravely wounded Ronald Reagan's
face and and in his eyes and that
concern comes from a love for his wife
and I think it's a rather beautiful
scene I think they were as close as two
people could be the strength of the bond
was undeniable you know Nancy says all
these things about Ronnie you know when
she met him that's when her life began
that she didn't really feel that her
life had begun before that her career
was to help him in every way he could to
make his make his dreams come true